Завод "Промприлад" - найстаріше підприємство Прикарпаття.
Йому понад 100 років.
У самісінькому центрі Івано-Франківська
він займає близько двох гектарів землі.
там ніякого руху немає...
закинутий завод.
Ну завод, старий завод.
Це Ярослав Добровольський.
На заводі він з 1989 року.
Каже, тоді підприємство було одним з основних виробників приладів
обліку газу. Та після розпаду Радянського Союзу
об’єми виробництва впали, штат скоротився.
В 90-ті роки, в принципі, завод ще працював нормально,
у нас ще було своє виробництво,
ливарний цех був,
в кінці,
де зараз знаходиться торговельно-розважальний комплекс.
А це підприємець Юрій Филюк.
Студентам-фінансистам він розповідає про платформу "Тепле місто"
та один з її проектів - "Промприлад".
Його мета - осучаснити територію заводу.
...Бізнес-інкубаторами, акселераторами,
мейкер спейс, фестивалі, івенти,
події і так далі.
На перетині нової економіки, сучасного мистецтва,
неформальної освіти і урбаністики
молодий підприємець разом із однодумцями
планує не лише відновити занедбану індустріальну зону,
але й активізувати малий і середній бізнес регіону.
Мотивацією слугує бажання не покидати рідне місто,
а покращити життя в ньому.
Перший етап заходу на цей об’єкт
починається з цієї тераси і весь третій поверх
на довжину цього корпуса.
Ми називаємо цей етап пілотним.
Тут 2200 квадратних метрів.
Ми його маємо привести в порядок і вже з вересня
має запрацювати перший поверх. Далі поетапно
наступний поверх і так корпус за корпусом.
Приводитись в порядок, запускатись.
Так завод має виглядати у 2020-му.
Успішна реалізація цієї ідеї може бути
прикладом відновлення багатьох постіндустріальних зон України.
Однак звідки гроші на все це?
На трьох основних рівнях ці гроші будуть збиратись:
це люди, це бізнеси, які зацікавленні в цьому проекті
і так звані імпактінвейст фундейшенз.
Тобто це фонди, які
шукають якесь рішення
на перетину бізнесу і соціального впливу.
Те, що соціальне підприємництво
може успішно існувати,
Юрій вже довів на прикладі кафе "Урбан100".
Аби його відкрити, 100 меценатів надали по тисячі доларів.
Нині значна частина з прибутку закладу фінансує
інші соціальні проекти.
Тут 200 квадратних метрів, а "Промприлад" - це 300 тисяч квадратних метрів,
і це, власне,  мало б стати остаточною точкою
неповернення, (щоб) перезапустити цілі системи.
Кафе - поруч з міською держадміністрацією
Івано-Франківська, де Юрій буває
ледь не щодня. Згадує, що спершу
узгодження кожної бізнес-ідеї тривало вкрай довго,
можливо, тому що влада не довіряла молодими реформаторам.
Та нині діалог налагоджується.
Для Ярослава завод - це майже 30 років його життя.
Йому все ще важко зрозуміти деякі революційні ідеї
молодих підприємців.
На даний час я є патріот виробництва.
Завод існував і повинен існувати.
Та насправді завод виставили на продаж.
Оточений багатоповерхівками,
якими активно забудовують місто, він взагалі міг би зникнути.
Молода команда "Теплого міста"
прагне дати йому друге життя - зберегти і назву,
і унікальні приміщення, а на базі архіву
створити історичні інсталяції.
У планах - вийти, як і колись в минулому, на міжнародний ринок.
Тільки тепер - продаючи не лічильники, а ідеї.